[Music]
sona i don't know about you but i got a
text this morning that said assemble the
team we're doing a recording that i
didn't even really know was gonna happen
and it felt like when the special squad
gets assembled regardless of what
they're doing in their lives you drop
everything and you know you and i have
three babies between us i dropped one of
my babies yeah
was it mikey or charlie which one which
one did you do i mean who knows at this
point i don't know wow
you're a terrific mom uh
i threw my baby across the air like a
football that my wife had said conan
literally you know batman has his bat
signal um and i have something that's
even cooler which is an email chain it
says i'd like us all to meet at your
convenience now that doesn't sound as
cool as a bat signal but think about it
in its own way it is no it's you realize
the modern batman would just get a text
the bat signal's stupid right it really
means the modern batman's just going to
be on a text chain and commissioner
gordon's going to be like yo
riddler
robbed the museum
and then batman's gonna be like on it
and then emoji like
you know uh what that shows the teeth oh
yeah this emoji
oh emoji or that one with the hands up
yeah what can i do
yeah like yeah busy i'm dealing with i'm
dealing with the joker you handled the
riddler well this is like you're in the
big metropolis right now yeah let me
explain what's happening i have come to
new york city um
i made up this it's kind of funny but
you know 25 years ago i just started
calling it the big apple and it caught
on oh jesus that was me
yeah is it called the big apple oh i'll
tell you why it's just a funny in joke
yeah why the apple why not like a banana
well it was going to be the rutabaga
it was rutabaga and then we decided to
change it
but anyway um i did that i called it the
big apple and then it just caught on
like a lot of things i invented
streaking i started that in the 70s
oh yeah yeah because i bet you streaked
in the 70s when you were like what nine
oh god i started when i was nine and
people thought it was disgusting um i
just looked like a kid who didn't have
any clothes my point is this and i
always say that after a particularly
stupid run
uh i'm in new york city uh to do some uh
fantastic podcast interviews so i've
flown here i went to boston first
visited my family drank a lot of dunkin
donuts and high five people wearing
boston red sox caps then
flew to new york last night and now i'm
in new york and this means
that at this moment i have more edge and
grit than either of you because you two
are both back in l.a
yeah which means we have a lot more to
chill yeah yeah you guys have a lot of
chill and you probably just had your
avocado toast
and
i had an avocado bath yeah you had a
bath and avocado fresh pureed avocado
while you were reading the trades about
you know the box office openings in the
weekend me but i'm here in new york
excuse me i'm sorry i'm saying yeah
that's what we do we read trades yeah
you're always reading the trades like oh
you know this pick
just phil you know
did well oh oh
that's a headline
are you a finance bro right now where
you don't understand the industry i just
don't really i've read a variety before
i'm an artist
i'm an artist i just create it's up to
you guys to read your traits you're just
doing some gorilla street theater right
now hey that's me me and banksy we're
always out doing our thing we're real
but my point is that i'm in new york
right now i've been walking around i've
got edge i've got grit i feel it right
now and and you two
feel very
weak
and
yeah uncultured compared to me i just
walked past a couple of museums you've
been there for like six hours i know and
you've been sleeping most of that yes
but in a very gritty hotel i'd like to
mention by the way that you're wearing
the most cozy like target great land
plaid black watch button up you look
like someone from home alone you're very
sweet and cozy looking that's not gritty
listen i'm doing my best to hide my grit
from my audience which has never seen me
like this i'm like charles bronson right
now in death oh my god i am i am a
gritty tough bourbon
you're just the opposite of death wish
you're like just mr mr love right now i
don't know
you just i was terrible you're not death
wish you're like
that's the worst
that was spoken like a guy
who's sitting in 80 degree weather
and he's wearing you know hey whatever i
don't know what i'm wearing i just threw
on a t-shirt i'm going to walk to the
corner and get a you know a smoothie
and
just enjoy the good vibes listen to the
beach boys
i'm here in the [ __ ] okay